[Music]
you are kendall roy you are
kendall roy is it true he's on his way
i don't see him yet with his stupid walk
no drama we're good i'm gonna
jump
the revolution will be televised
he's our dad but he was gonna send me to
jail he'd do the same to all of us
chev are you okay are you part of this
family or not
if i back you against death you would
need to let me take over
whoa nilly everyone's going to battle in
armor and i'm
sitting here exposed logan is going to
fire a million poisonous spiders down
your dickie
that that sounds like kind of dramatic
tom
ask yourself do you want to be on the
side of good for
people you tell them i'm gonna grind
these
bones to make my bread he says
he's going to grind your bones to make
his breath
okay tell him that i'm gonna run up off
the
[Music]
beanstalk
you